given the desire the country to see an
outcome that will get to us we're gonna
the cloture vote at 3:00 as you know is
on a shell and we expect it to get on to
the shell and hope we will have
cooperation ilio lead lead give us a
time to get on the bill without burning
all of the post-cloture time on the
motions to proceed what we have to be
alert to here is one House Democrat for
example said this is a tremendous
opportunity to restructure things to fit
our vision that's not what this is about
this is not about unrelated policy
changes this is about direct assistance
to the American people and to small
businesses to hospitals and others who
are in need because we in government at
all levels in order to deal with this
pandemic have basically shut the economy
down the crisis is bringing the country
together we are doing all kinds of
inspirational stories about how people
are reaching out to others and they're
expecting us to do our part and we fully
intend to do that tomorrow
with that I'll take a couple of
questions and that's basically all I
could tell you at the moment yeah well
you'd have to ask her what we intend to
do here in the Senate hmm is to move
forward with a Senate bill I'm hopeful
and optimistic we'll get bipartisan
support because this bill has been
negotiated on a bipartisan basis here in
the Senate it best for the country if
the house would take it up and pass it
just like we did earlier this week when
the House passed a bill that I had only
marginal participation in because the
country
was desperate for results so I hope
that's the way this ends I believe
that's the way it'll end and that's the
way we're gonna go forward yeah yeah
we're still we're still talking to them
but procedurally the way it works
cloture will be invoked on a shell not
the actual bill there's 30 hours of
post-cloture time I hope we don't use
all that 30 hours and we're still
talking about those issues where there's
still some disagreement but make no
mistake about it we'll be boating
tomorrow I mean the wheel has to stop at
some point and I don't want any of you
to buy the notion that this isn't a
thoroughly bipartisan proposal already
there's still some elbowing and
maneuvering for room as you can imagine
but this is a pretty solidly bipartisan
proposal agreed to buy a lot of
rank-and-file democrats who were
involved in drafting it and at some
point here will have to stop and that'll
be the bill that we vote on and in my
opinion that will be tomorrow thank you